tu n'es jamais allé en train de tremper je suis
très précaire nous y allons maintenant mais
je pense qu'il y a un gland qui cache ton
pubis tais-toi j'ai dit en train de tremper maigre hein
mini dippin j'aurais dû aller
directement à New York  nouveau travail
allez mec c'est ton père d'accord tu
peux gérer ça est-ce qu'il habite là-bas
hé
papa prends des mannequins je n'ai pas apporté de
maillot de bain problème résolu les filles
[Applaudissements]
ici a essayé de me combattre que feriez-
vous ce genre de résumé Je prendrais mes
coups comme un vrai Américain et qui
combattriez-vous Je combattrais totalement votre
père laissez-moi le dire de cette façon mon père ressemble
à un muppet humain et je suis  à cent
pour cent sûr qu'il pourrait donner un coup de pied à ton père qu'est
-ce que tu penses gagnerait il est beaucoup plus grand
que toi il est probablement sobre ce qui est un
énorme plus
sais-tu combien de combats j'ai participé
je ne sais pas six sept si tu  Comptez ce
petit coup de poussière que j'ai dû utiliser
comme s'il avait perdu toute foi, il y a une tempête qui se
prépare  ng sur Maple Street, je suis ici pour
régler ce débat sur les enfants un
temps paradisiaque quel est le débat, nous ne nous
soucions pas vraiment de vous, les gars, vous vous battez, je
pense que vous avez cinq secondes pour
balancer, j'ai 3 2 et cette
flotte de gazelles
[  Musique]
comment se fait-il que tu ne sois pas à New York,
j'ai frappé mon père d'un toit Joey ouais
et puis ils nous ont arrêtés tu sais avec
ton seul appel téléphonique hier soir tu
m'as appelé et j'ai perdu mon travail
alors tu vas dessiner  les charges me
rendent fou je vais abandonner les charges que diriez-vous d'un bain d'oiseaux pourquoi je n'ai
pas d'oiseaux j'ai gâché sa vie assez
mal je dois arranger les choses
je viens de nous avoir une réunion c'est G nous
obtenons  ton boulot qu'est-ce que tu
fais je vais arranger ça pour toi
non c'est notre V notre espace de rencontre oh mon
dieu je suis un kangourou tout le monde
certaines personnes disent que je suis instable et je claque
mon dieu c'était un claquement de
toi